this couple extremists their 50-year  anniversary surprising they never met me  we don't know who we are we're covering  their bill see their reaction  my boo okay loud answer  pretty wild stuff us you must be  celebrity when you travel as much as you  do well listen it's not every day you  get married 50 years I figured I'd get  your bill tonight so congratulations to  you guys yeah big deal we should  celebrate your fifth year it's the least  we could do it's the most we need more  stories like yours absolutely go enjoy  your sari - thank you most afternoon  happy anniversary fifth years a long  time they deserve more than just a  gentle being covered by surprise